l'algue marines et la plante de la mine
depuis 15 ans jean pierre gagnon et
carmen vaillancourt récolte des algues
sur les berges du saint-laurent
ils le font sous l'oeil attentif du
gouvernement fédéral on les coupe à 15
cm il ne faut pas les archers sinon ils
poussent ont pu puis ou trois ans pour
venir dans le même secteur qu'on était
puis sont même plus longue parce que on
les a dégagées ont coupés qu'on les ait
coupés puis j'ai fait que cette même ça
lui fait vivre
par la suite les algues sont séchées et
transformé en granules ou en farine
jusqu'ici elle servait surtout comme
fertilisant en agriculture ou un
jardinage ou même pour des traitements
de thalassothérapie
mais l'an dernier un nouveau marché
s'est ouvert avec un client en chine et
fait view place thé offert des sandales
lui c'est de la granule d'algues marines
mais plus grosse que sa vie c'est de la
graine qui achète environ stagne à 9,1
les algues marines mes amis a transformé
par les européens les chinois eux ça
fait des siècles utilise en pis ou
québec s'est même les états unis
s'engagent sur cette voie des
bioplastiques le potentiel de croissance
y est telle que l'entreprise espère y
faire une percée
entre-temps et nous terrifie une
modernisation de ses équipements qui lui
permettrait de récolter et traiter cinq
fois plus d'alcool actuellement est de
tripler son personnel faut investir dans
dans nos machinerie fixé de faire
l'exploitation industrielle avec notre
machinerie qu on m a dit on embauchera
une vingtaine de personnes devant cet
engouement d'autres pays ont entrepris
de cultiver des ags dans des
environnement protégé ici on explore un
débouché inattendu c'est un fertilisant
naturel
ça sert à les jardins les plates-bandes
même du pélousse elle cannabis aussi
surtout qu'elle mais simon paul cannabis
la culture de cannabis comme le crabe à
une autre époque les algues apparaissent
comme une richesse présente depuis
toujours mais insoupçonnées ici denis
leduc radio-canada à rimouski